[Musique]
Giraud
Hello
et dans le 11e arrondissement de Paris
là encore de nombreuses victimes à
déplorer effectivement ce qui se passe
en ce moment dans la salle de spectacle
des hommes qui seraient retranchés après
les fusillades qui ont été classés à
l'intérieur de la salle de spectacle y
a-t-il d'autres hommes en fuite en ce
moment dans les rues de Paris pour
les gars
le bouquet est en route pour l'instant
le négociateur essaie d'entrer en
contact avec les terreaux
dès qu'on peut on entre avec les secours
alors on se tient prêt OK
[Musique]
quand on va rentrer faudra demander au
secouriste d'attendre un petit peu le
temps qu'on sécurise c'est pas
exactement ce que vous voulez faire mais
on sera en mesure de donner le premier
soin
j'étais au COS j'ai fait deux ans en
Syrie à mon avis les gars à l'intérieur
aussi parce que vous pouvez pas faire ça
si vous avez pas vu quelqu'un d'autre à
faire
ils vont pas négocier
celles qui vont mourir ce soir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
installez-vous le dossier de la semaine
Ahmed à marcja donc 20 ans casier
judiciaire profond les ports d'armes
habite dans un logement social de la
ville de Melun Levallois vient de passer
son dossier en rouge donc il est très
actif sur les forums essayer de se
procurer des armes sur le Dark web ça
fait une semaine qui laisse des
commentaires dans lesquels il promet de
passer à l'acte donc j'ai reçu un coup
de fil de la date il faut que ça soit
nous d'aller chercher ok quand vous
dites le chercher vous voulez dire chez
lui
parce que ici on a une manière un peu à
nous de travailler à moins que ce soit
un mec super recherché archi chaud bon
on attend qu'il sorte et on pète dehors
en dynamique
et pourquoi vous fonctionnez comme ça
parce que n'importe quel tocard chez lui
il se tient prêt on porte un gilet et
puis je sa porte et dehors il a pas le
temps de comprendre ce qui lui arrive il
est perdu mais après dehors il peut
avoir son arme papa son gilet aussi et
puis vous savez ce qui adore
moi je vous le dis c'est un fatigué
d'avoir son écran il appelle au jihad
mais en vrai elle attend juste de
toucher son RSA il fera du tout il va se
mettre à pleurer quand je le passerai la
manette on prend les paris si vous
voulez mais mon travail c'est pas de
prendre des paris donc on fera comme
j'ai dit comme vous voulez mais
l'expérience moi je sais que ce genre
d'individus
que vous croyez moi beaucoup plus
c'est pas pour le défendre parce que
généralement dit beaucoup de conneries
avec Patrick ça va qu'on fonctionner
comme ça et on n'a jamais loupé une
interpellation bon de toute façon c'est
pas encore sûr qu'on doit y aller ça
sera peut-être un autre groupe
plus de respect le premier briefing du
nouveau patron toi tu es déjà au
téléphone
ça bouge
c'est quoi poisson
là c'est rien du tout c'est un ancien
voyou chômage et donc il fait raconter
aux jeunes comment c'était les tirelire
c'est tout ouais
je pense ça
il fait plein de rendez-vous avec des
mecs bien sûr
de prison tu veux qu'il voit qui des
philosophes des écrivains c'est un voyou
les voyous ils connaissent
Dior chez Zenia il a une nouvelle
Audemar au poignet
surtout les voleurs ils ont pas de
revenus fixes donc à mon humble la ville
encore dans la course s'il dépense à ce
rythme là c'est qui c'est qu'il a une
rentrée d'argent ou alors il a un
acompte sur un contrat
qu'est-ce que tu en penses toi
je sais pas
discuter sans sept ans je vais aller et
puis on verra c'est quoi le plan
le voiturier du Monaco
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
écoutez je suis je suis pas bon à tout
ça
j'aime pas trop parler et tout là tu
vois bien moi tu me mets dans mon
couloir et puis je suis le meilleur à ce
que je fais Berry c'est la brigade de
recherche et d'intervention c'est les
deux d'accord donc si tu voulais que
doper
autre chose OK et si on fonctionne sur
le renseignement d'accord vous savez
maintenant ici faites versatile
à chaque fois
il a la retraite et moi je peux pas
Patrick tout ce que je te dis là c'est
pas pour te faire chier
parce que je veux c'est que tu fasses
des propositions je veux que tu trouves
des indices tu ramènes des affaires
qu'au sein du groupe tu sautes
je vais te poser une question
est-ce que je pose problème au sein du
groupe
alors pourquoi tu veux tout changer
comme ça
bonjour Julien ça y est je peux avoir
une minute merci alors comment ça se
passe cette première journée ça va
on a pas eu le temps d'en parler mais
j'ai trouvé le candidat idéal pour
intégrer votre groupe
Patrick lui a fait passer les entretiens
avant de partir
[Musique]
4 ans là-bas ces résultats sur le
terrain exceptionnel c'est tout de suite
intégré à la rue
moi je peux le comprendre parce qu'ils
sont un peu spéciaux
enfin bref il a passé les tests il a
explosé tout le monde et depuis il
attend qu'une place se libère chez nous
arrête de bouger là tu peux pas taper
ton salaire de merde
pourquoi là c'est bon
pour la
tête parle de réponse
[Musique]
désolé j'ai même pas eu le temps de vous
en parler
[Musique]
meilleur candidat
comment vous vous sentez ça va
mon groupe
même si il est quand même assez
hétérogène croyez-moi j'ai rarement vu
une aussi bonne équipe non mais des
cadres que j'ai sous mes ordres à
Versailles gardez le pot c'est le
meilleur groupe
bon ça c'est pas fait du jour au
lendemain évidemment Patrick a vraiment
fait un travail monstre on peut faire
quelques ajustements quand même ah oui
c'est normal on peut toujours
s'améliorer
mais le mieux est l'ennemi du bien
vous avez parmi les meilleurs éléments
de la région parisienne faites-vous
respecter deux comme Patrick et tout ira
parfaitement
ils veulent voir si on fait ce qu'on dit
si on est réellement
[Musique]
ils veulent voir si on vise qu'on dit si
on en Crète ils veulent voir si on vit
ce qu'on dit si on est rien fait
il est toujours dedans il est en train
de manger qui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis à la salle
tu crois que c'est que Zelda Blanco
c'est juste la meuf qui va se taper ce
soir
on est fini ton gars moi je te le dis
ça pue ton truc là c'est toi qui pue
tu vas finir comme Julien à force de
bouffer toutes ces protéines tu auras
plus de cerveau
mais voilà une nuit blanche pour rien
ils vont aller soit chez elle soit à
l'hôtel
de dormir là j'ai préféré venir avec toi
galérer sur une filature maintenant
c'est toi qui me fait galérer à suivre
au chômage
de deux tu es une d'insomniaque à
l'envers
remarque j'aurais pu me faire embarquer
dans une affaire entre Julien qui dit
rien et celui de qui t'explique la vie
alors qu'il connaît rien du tout
protéger comme ça Patrick qui dit que
c'était une pointure enseignement
qu'est-ce que ça à voir avec ce qu'on
fait il a juste fait le Bataclan sa
première semaine au 36
des fois
rentre chez toi va dormir
tu fais quoi là tu es con ou quoi
c'est moins cher
[Musique]
ça va je voulais te faire la surprise tu
as vu comme il est beau mon neveu
tu fais quoi
non je rigole
mission il t'envoie aussi
tes secteur par secteur mais maintenant
ils font des économies tout ça bon
vraiment
bon courage
[Musique]
63 7 je pensais que j'avais pris
plus
je galère à chaque fois qu'on passe en
lourd là les plaquettes c'est la moitié
de mon poids
tu peux pas de façon
avec moi
tu crois que j'ai envie de t'avoir tout
transpirant sur moi
je te remercie
ça va ou quoi
alors
[Musique]
grâce au travail de Vanessa et Badri on
lance un petit peu plus sur un Pixi
alias poisson
il fréquente une fille qui travaille à
l'Hôtel du Louvre la semaine prochaine
c'est la Fashion Week il y a une grande
chanteuse américaine qui a réservé la
plus grande suite elle arrive dans deux
jours donc on pense qu'il est sur le
point de taper là comment il s'appelle
c'est marqué
[Rires]
une deuxième Kardashian tout le monde
compte sur nous donc vraiment là
j'insiste sinon demain c'est simulations
et le thème s'est prise d'otage oui ça
sera avec un nouvel élément qui viendra
compléter le groupe et qui ne vient tout
droit des stups
en montant dans la voiture il s'était
tiré une balle dans le pied c'est con
j'espère que c'est pas lui qui a formé
ton gars parce qu'on est dans la merde
rassurez-vous c'est le grand Patrick qui
l'a recruté donc ça devrait vous
rassurer tous
bon signe Patrick
parce qu'il a éclaté tout le monde au
test et si ça se trouve il va tous vous
mettre une branlée
donc on verra ça demain
pour tout le monde
c'est triste à dire mais bon ouais c'est
malheureux
c'est malheureux
sinon tu as pu voir pour moi pour mon
truc
j'arrête
pas de quoi
fini c'est peut-être fini pour toi mais
c'est pas fini pour moi je veux bien me
filer le numéro de mon remplaçant mais
maintenant les informations c'est plus
comme avant il faut les rentrer au
fichiers national je crois pas que tu as
envie d'avoir ton nom là dedans
donc mon numéro je vais me démerder
comment
as-tu la carte
du coup ils m'ont foutu en congé de
temps de les rattraper mais ouais je
bosse plus
je suis en dispo au cas où ils auraient
besoin de moi je fais un peu de
formation mais ouais je prends le plus
rien j'attends juste le coup de tampon
je m'attendais pas
tu as plus envie c'est pas ça
depuis combien de temps on se connaît
toi c'était mieux avant c'était le point
là
comme les anciens toi
je suis devant les urgences
les frangins ils ont décidé de pas payer
ils ont dit que si je revenais ça allait
mal se passer tu as compris alors
[Applaudissements]
bonjour
[Musique]
tu as compris
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors
cette première comment ça se passe
sur ton affaire
un exercice
je continue
très bien
je suis dessus
ça roule ça roule
salut
on se connaît
qui m'a dit de venir te parler
maintenant qu'il arrête
je vais te parler de gars qui commence à
menacer tout Paris pendant que ça porte
en couille
je t'avais tout de suite
donc on va pas discuter
as quand tu l'auras parlé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de prendre tes patins
est-ce que ça dit quelque chose
j'ai un double appel là c'est mon fils
qui m'appelle je te rappelle attends
qu'est-ce que je fais avec le gars
tu me dis que tu connais pas je te
laisse
[Musique]
tu bosses un peu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est bon ça va
encore tu veux faire du MMA
[Musique]
pourquoi tu es une relax à 15 balles
c'est important les montres
si j'avais quelque part avec une Roro
comme ça ça passe si j'arrive avec une
gel choc comme ça là c'est fini je cramé
direct et ta coupe de cheveux bizarre ça
suffit pas à passer inaperçu
on va se boire des bières et manger des
pizzas
je te rejoins
dépêche-toi de bonheur je vais pas faire
trop tard
[Musique]
et du mouvement Peugeot 508 noir
et des 42 pour des 41 en place
41 pour des 44 45 je confirme pour la
508 ça se garde devant 3 individus on a
Poisson perruque et lunettes un grand
veste noir chemise bleu et un petit
veste bleu pull noir
il faut surtout pas qu'il nous fasse
sortir lui mettre les pinces
[Musique]
dans le couloir
vous arrivez au niveau de la chambre là
ils vont taper
ils vont taper là ils vont taper
[Musique]
la
bouge pas
[Musique]
super les gars je vous laisse finaliser
ok on se voit pour le champagne
allô allô
parle pas avec moi toi
tu m'as eu le jeu je pars dedans pour
longtemps
sur mon téléphone il y a des gens avec
qui je parle sur silent ils ont rien à
voir je veux pas les mettre dans la
merde
et donne-moi une bonne raison de faire
ça
je te donne un dégâts de Fontainebleau
ce qu'on fait la salle de bains
c'est un vrai fils de je le déteste
tu l'as lui tu auras les autres
je t'écoute
[Musique]
j'ai parlé avec ferratier alors tu
réfléchis tu me dis d'accord bon allez
je te laisse on se parle vite merci au
revoir
[Musique]
arrête de faire la gueule tu vas manger
une pizza
tu sais quoi
tu as de la chance pourquoi Alix va pas
venir ce soir elle vient de m'envoyer un
message tu es content
on va faire quoi maintenant on va aller
manger cette pizza
j'ai juste un petit rendez-vous avant
mais ça
[Musique]
je m'occupe de votre fils
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]